welcome everyone
and thank you for joining us for our
presentation titled
applications of high throughput gene
expression
profiling and early drug discovery it's
my pleasure to introduce you to peter
messack a senior as scientist at the bio
gazelle and associate professor
of the faculty of medicine and health
sciences at penn
university in belgium for complete
biography of our speaker
please visit the tab at the top of your
screen
now if any questions arise during the
presentation we encourage you to submit
those questions
in the q a box our speaker will address
your questions following the end of the
presentation
please join me now in welcoming our
presenter peter
you may now present your presentation
welcome sir
so thank you for the introduction and um
thank you for attending
um what i would like to do today is
introduce
uh a novel technology basically two
novel technologies that we have
developed to enable
height through putrine expression
profiling
with applications in the various phases
of early drug discovery
the technologies i would like to present
today are shown here they're called
hd pathway c can hd target seek
so ht pathway seek is a technology that
enables height throughput gene
expression profiling
to reveal pathway level information
and from the path level information
various
aspects relevant during early drug
discovery can be inferred for instance
the mechanism of action
of your compounds molecular toxicity
profiles that may be induced or
repressed by your compounds of interests
or molecular similarities between
compounds that have been identified
during
early phases or early stages of drug
discovery
on the other hand i will also talk about
a
derivative technology called hd target
seek
so hd target c goes beyond hd pathway
seek in a sense that it goes beyond
generating pathway level information but
also generates
gene level information and more
specifically differential gene
expression
information and we believe this
technology can play a very important
role
during phases of oligonucleotide drug
development
and more specifically identifying
on and off target effects induced by
oligonucleotide drugs for instance
anti-sensory nucleotides or sir
now i want to just take a few minutes to
to make sure i position the technology
and that it's clear where we believe
this can play a role so during the early
phases of drug discovery what you would
typically do once you have identified a
number of compounds of
interest that targets
your target of interest is that you can
use various
types of assays to establish the
activity of those compounds so these
could be simple reporter assays or
certain phenotypic readouts
but these assays are typically
relatively simple in their readout
and therefore do not do not reveal a lot
of information
on let's say the mechanism of action
of your compound and what happens really
uh
at the molecular level and so
uh what we believe is that and we
together with others
is that rna profiling
during those stages of drug development
could actually help
in further characterizing prioritizing
the drugs
that are under investigation during
these stages
so rna profiling has a lot of upside
potential here
you can use the rna profile to establish
activity of pathways and
biological functions this type of
information can
complement your phenotypic readouts and
help to further prioritize
your drugs so you really have access to
an extensive molecular profile derived
from these
rna profiling studies and
important to mention also is that
generating an rna profile is really
generic test
gene expression profiling does not
depend on the type of cell line that
you're using
type of compound that you're applying to
your cells the type of target that you
have it's really a generic test that
does not require any customization
uh depending on the project uh the
target the cell line and so on
of course there's a number of technology
requirements involved in order to
implement such
um to implement rna profiling during
drug development and for
the first requirement is that your
technology needs to
be compatible with a high throughput
setting so the technology
should allow you to profile several
compounds and several different
concentrations and different cell lines
all in one experiment
and in a cost effective manner of course
and secondly your technology should also
provide you with sufficient coverage of
the transcriptome
to enable you to infer activities of
pathways and to generate molecular
profiles in a robust and reliable
rna sequencing is obviously a technology
that
matches all of those criteria so rna
sequencing allows us to profile the
expression of thousands of genes
however in its current classic form
it's not really amenable to high
throughput applications
and it's not really cost effective so we
decided to develop a technology that
we termed hd pathway seek that allows us
to
apply an rna sequencing technology but
really in a high throughput and cost
effective
setup and the way this works is shown
here so basically we're applying this
rna sequencing technology directly to
crude cell lysates
and this of course has a number of
advantages because we're circumventing
cumbersome rna extraction laborious rna
extraction steps
so the library preparation is actually
performed directly on
cell lysate so basically you treat your
cells in 96 wild cell culture plates
with your compounds of interest or other
genetic perturbations that you want to
apply to those cells
utilize the cells we typically recommend
to use for
biological replicates per condition
utilize the cells
and the on those lysates we actually
perform this technology
so it's a three prime and rna sequencing
based technology
and again libraries are generated
directly from cell lysates
another important thing to to note here
is the fact that we apply
shallow rna sequencing so in the hd
pathway seek approach we will only
generate an average one million reads
for each of the samples for hd target
seek we increase that number to 5
million i will come back to that later
but so sequencing these lysates at 1
million read coverage
we on average detect around 7 000 genes
in each of the samples and then of
course there's a number of data analysis
procedures
that will reveal underlying pathway
changes
so let me just quickly show you some
some quality data of this procedure so
this is hd pathway seek data
applied to 384 different samples which
is a typical
number of samples that we include in a
single experiment so we can of course do
multiple experiments
so on the left hand side you can see the
cumulative fraction of the number of
detected genes so you can see that on
average
this is around 7 000 genes in some
samples a bit less and over samples it's
a bit more
the middle plot shows you the read
coverage so you can see that the read
coverage is really focused at the three
prime ends of the genes
hence three prime end sequencing of
course and
in the right hand side you can see uh
the reproducibility of the reed counts
that are generated so these are
technical replicates that
are included in the same plate and so
you can see a very high reproducibility
despite the fact that these libraries
are generated
directly on cell lysates and were
sequenced at a very shallow
sequencing depth of 1 million weeks
next step is of course data analysis so
what is typically done is differential
gene expression analysis between
different uh conditions of interest your
compounds compared to vehicle
vehicle controls or other negative
controls so any type of comparison as
possible followed by
a gene set enrichment analysis to reveal
the pathways that are significantly
activated or repressed
in each of the conditions in your
experiment
and so we use gene set enrichment
analysis because
it's a very sensitive approach um and
it has been shown in at least in the
class of non-topology-based
pathway analysis tools to uh basically
outperform all of the other tools that
are available we use various types of
gene set collections both publicly
available gene set collections
from the molecular signatures database
but also custom gene sets that you may
have
available
we also did some analysis to uh
demonstrate that
even with just 7000 genes you can
actually
reveal all the relevant pathways that
are differentially expressed upon
certain perturbation and so to do so we
simulated
uh situations using real life data sets
these are three different real-life data
sets
where we either use all of the genes to
do a differential gene and pathway
analysis or just use the 7000 most
abundant genes which are typically the
ones that we detect with hd pathway seek
and then compare to the output
of the pathway analysis and as you can
see here um
the pathways that are shared between
both conditions so being
on the one hand side using all of the
genes on the other side using
um only the seven thousand most abundant
genes you can see that the majority of
the pathways that are identified are
actually shared between both conditions
meaning that even with just seven
thousand genes
you can basically retrieve the relevant
pathways
that are either activated or inactivated
in your data set
so we believe this methodology can
actually reveal insights in
the mechanism of action of your compound
it can reveal
insights in certain box pathways that
may be activated upon
compound treatments but we can also use
it for instance to compare
the profiles you have
generated with your compounds of
interest to profiles
generated for drugs with established
mechanisms of action and i just want to
show you uh
briefly highlights a few of the analysis
that are possible
and some data demonstrating uh the the
power of this
procedure so this is uh these are
results from a project that we did where
we screened actually
90 different compounds including vehicle
controls and some compounds with known
mechanisms of action as positive
controls on the screen
so for a total of 380 samples more or
less
and uh so one of the positive control
compounds in this case was for instance
dsa
trichostatin a it's an htac inhibitor
and so when we did the
the hd pathway seek analysis for those
samples that
the differential gene expression
analysis pathway enrichment and so on
we could clearly see uh htac related
pathways pathways related to tsa
treatment appearing among the top
differentially expressed pathways
induced by this tsa treatment by
anesthesia compounds
so suggesting that hdpc can indeed
identify relevant pathways that are
associated to
the drug's mechanism of action
you can also reveal those dependent
relationships between
compound concentration on the one hand
and pathway activation on the other hand
so on the left you see an example of a
compound
where certain pathways are only induced
at the highest concentration
on the right hand side you can see an
example of a compound
where the pathways are already induced
at the lowest concentrations and you see
a very nice dose-dependent
increase in pathway activity for the
specific compounds and you can really
look at those relationships between
compound concentration and pathway
activation or repression
you can also compare compounds relative
to each other based on their underlying
molecular phenotype
so based on the gene expression data and
pathway level expression data that's
generated
you can actually create what we call
compound similarity matrices
where you can compare compounds relative
to each other and identify compounds
that induce
a similar molecular phenotype this is
information you can afterwards correlate
for instance to the chemical structure
of the compounds
or correlate to the cellular phenotype
that is induced by those compounds
finally
uh and another application
is uh basically using those molecular
profiles to
reveal potential cox pathways so a
number of canonical talks pathways have
been defined some of them are listed
here like dna damage oxidative stress e
r stress and so on
and so for each of these stocks pathways
we have one or multiple gene sets that
represent
box pathway activity and so what we can
then do is to look at
the induction or repression of these
pathways for each of the compounds
included in the screen and by doing so
you could be able to upfront
during those early phases of drug
discovery
already try to predict or get insights
into potential toxicity
mechanisms that are activated when
adding your compounds
to to the cells or evaluate at what
concentration
do you start to see induction of certain
unwanted toxicity pathways
now this entire technology comes with a
very diverse suit of data analysis tools
that actually allow you to
browse and navigate through all of the
information because it's a lot of
information that's being generated in a
single experiment
and so these tools that we have
developed actually allow you to browse
through all of that information
in a user-friendly way i will just
briefly show you
what the tool can do so this is a
tool that you can access once the data
has been generated and uploaded this is
something
that is part of uh standardly standardly
integrated into these projects
so you can get overviews more general
overviews of the results
or go into more detail into individual
contrasts
and again look at toxicity similarity
and so on just highlight a few things
so you can get an overview this is an
experiment with 72 different
compounds you can get an overview of the
number of
positively and negatively enriched
pathways and gene sets for each of the
contrasts
but you can also zoom in on certain
contrasts for instance a certain
compound in a certain cell line that was
administered in different concentrations
and then see
how the number of enriched gene sets is
correlated for instance in this case to
the concentration of the compounds this
is again a very nice example of a
compound where you see a dose-dependent
impact on activated and repressed
pathways in these cells
you can also zoom into individual
contrasts this is again
the example of the trichostatin a that
was added
at a certain concentration to a certain
cell line and
you can actually pull up or reveal all
of the
significantly enriched gene sets that
are either activated
or repressed upon treatment with the
compounds with all of the statistics
associated to them
links that allow you to review more
information about the content of these
gene sets
and you can also select individual gene
sets and reveal
the underlying data so the gene central
analysis plots
and to the right hand side a table
showing you
which genes from that gene sets are
actually contributing
to the enrichment so the so-called core
enrichment genes
that actually drive the enrichment so
for all of these genes you get
individual statistics again
what was their fault change in the
in the experiment and so forth
you can also reveal a two-dimensional
plots
uh or or generate two-dimensional plots
that reveal
relationships uh between different
treatments so these are
different compounds that are clustered
here um
in a two-dimensional disney plot um
allowing you to reveal uh whether
certain compounds are more similar or
more related
to which compared to others
and finally you can also reveal these
toxicity profiles these toxicity maps
where
these canonical tox pathways are shown
and um with indication whether they are
positively
positively or negatively enriched for
each of the compounds
and the conditions included in the
screen so a number of tools that allow
you
to browse through the results to
generate
figures that you can download and so on
so that's hd pathway seek and i want to
go one step further and talk about let's
say a derivative technology that is
uh i mean from a from an analytical
point of view in a technological point
of view
uh identical to hd pathway seek but
uh differs in the fact that
we generate a bit more reads we sequence
a bit deeper
to enable really gene expression level
analysis and
we're positioning this technology really
in the field of
oligonucleotide drug development where
it could have a number of applications
so um only nucleotide drug development
for instance antisense oligonucleotides
is iras so these
processes typically involve several
hundreds of candidates
that are screened for their impact on
reducing target expression
they're typically also selected based on
the on-target knockdown efficiency
but we know of course that these
molecules also have
a number of target cheats
and what we think this hd target seek
technology can do is to help reveal
those off-target jeeps and and
having access to that information can
actually guide or further steer
oligonucleotide drug developments you
can for instance evaluate whether
certain chemical modifications may
improve
uh the off-target repertoire whether
formulation of dosing
or dosing has an impact on the
off-target repertoire you name it
a second application is not an
oligonucleotide drug development but
actually in repurposing
data from sir a or shrna library screens
so these screens
are typically or can be heavily affected
by of target effects as well
and it's been shown in several research
papers that
gaining insights in the off-target
effects that are induced
during these srna library screens that
these insights can actually reveal novel
players in the pathways that are being
studied and potentially reveal
novel therapeutic targets and i will
come back to that later to show you
a study that we've done and that
actually
allowed us to do that now
the way this is normally achieved is
purely
from a bioinformatics point of view
where the mechanism by which these of
target effects are induced
are actually used to predict for each of
the si rnas that you would
have in such a screen predict what their
off-target repertoire could be
so you probably know or you don't know
that
off-target genes induced by sr cyrnates
are actually
um of target genes induced to a
microrna-like action of sir so through
seed binding in complementary seed
binding
um between these ira and
the target messenger rna this is how
off-target genes are being induced and
so there's a number of
uh tools that have been developed that
purely rely on bioinformatic predictions
of target genes using the srna seed
sequence
but there's a number of disadvantages
when relying
only on bioinformatic approaches so
first of all
you can have many false positive
predictions the seed sequences that we
are referring to here are very short
sequences six seven nucleotides in
length
so you can find typically a lot of
matches uh for these sequences
uh in utrs of uh of of messenger rnas
so a lot of false positive predictions
and on top of that
these predictions do not provide you any
information on the magnitude
of the of target effects so you may have
enough target that is regulated is
repressed by 20
but some other of target genes may be
repressed by 80 or 90
so there's no information on the
magnitude of the effect if you only rely
on bioinformatic approaches to predict
of targets of uh
of oregon nucleotides in this case this
example is ir x
so by integrating gene expression data
and on top of that differential gene
expression analysis
you can actually further fine-tune the
selection and the repertoire of targets
in such an experiment
so by combining genes that are down
regulated upon sir a treatment
with the presence or absence of seed
binding sites
for the sirna that was included in the
experiment
you can actually further narrow down the
list of
of target genes fine-tune it and on top
of that
also get an idea on the magnitude of the
effect the sir a has
on its off-target repertoire of course
doing that again requires
methods that enable high throughput gene
expression profiling a very cost
effective method and this is again where
in this case hd target seek kicks in so
it's the same technology as hd pathway
seek it's also performed directly on
cell lysates
um the only difference is that instead
of generating one million reads per
sample
we uh go a bit higher here we go for
five million reads per sample so it's
five times higher sequencing depth
why because um it
will provide you with a bit more
coverage on genes and have
identify a bit more genes and really be
able to do reliable differential gene
expression analysis
uh so going beyond the pathway level
analysis where you're combining
information from multiple genes
and then it's not that important to have
highly accurate gene expression readouts
whereas if you really want to focus on
the individual gene readouts and
differentially expressed genes you need
to have sufficient coverage
so as mentioned i want to show what this
technology can do
using a case study where we have applied
hd target seek
in an sir a screen repurposing study
so in this case this was an s iron a
screen that was
performed in the context of fibrosis uh
where
the readout was a tgf beta driven
phenotype so with a tgf beta reporter
readout 1716 genes were actually
screened
using this library approach with three
different siris per gene so a total of
close to 5 000 s irnas that were
screened
for their activity to induce or repress
this tgf
driven phenotype and readouts so hits
were basically genes that would repress
tgf-beta signaling
upon logda and typically those screens
will reveal two types
of two types of hits two types of genes
the example of gene a is an example
where all three sirnas give knock down
of the target in this case gene a
and will also induce the phenotype of
interests so gene
a here is a gene that will be classified
as a hit
where meaning that gene a is involved in
repressing
uh in this case tgf beta signal but
a number of cases are actually more like
gene b
where um all of these iras would induce
target knockdown but only one of these
iras induces the phenotype of interest
so suggesting here that it's iron a3
directed against gene b
is actually mediating the phenotype true
of target effects
not by knocking down gene b but really
by knocking down one or multiple of
target genes
and so identifying those genes could
reveal novel players
in the pathway of interest so there's a
lot of hidden information
in these library screens that can be
revealed by applying these hd target c
technology and i will show you uh what
we've done in this case
so 86s irnas were selected that show to
this type of behavior
so with presumed off-target effects a
number of positive controls and negative
controls were also included
amongst others as irnas against the tgsb
receptor one and two
as known repressors while if you would
knock down tgbt receptor one or two you
would get regression of tj beta
signaling so these were the positive
controls
so applying hd target seek to again this
was a total of around 384
samples um i'll just show you some of
the results from the positive controls
and then move to the uh
the of target this irnase so here you
can see as iron against tjf beta
receptor one on the left
teaches beta receptor two on the right
um
we can the the methods reveals very
clear knockdown
of tgsb receptor one expression and tjsp
receptor two expression
we can also see that at the pathway
level these knockdowns are functional
you can see a lot of tgf beta related
gene sets that are significantly
repressed
in both of those positive control
conditions suggesting that we
are capable of detecting differential
expression of individual genes and also
of uh individual pathways
um so when doing differential expression
analysis for these irons of interest
those 86 is iron as we presumed of
target effects it was really interesting
interesting to see
that for most if not all of these irnas
we could identify
a few dozen up to several hundreds of
genes
that were significantly repressed when
treating the cells with those individual
si rnas
so we could identify both up-regulated
and down-regulated genes but with a
clear
bias towards the down-regulated genes so
many more down-regulated genes and
upregulated genes suggesting that
there's a number of targets
there that may be responsible for
driving the phenotype
that these irons are inducing so the
proof of the pudding is in the eating
and
so if this is really the case then what
we expect to see
is that genes that have a seed site for
these
sirnas are actually preferentially down
regulated in the data
so before i show you the results i just
want to quickly
give us or give a brief overview of
these different
seat matches that we consider so this is
coming from
the micro rna world where you have the
canonical seed matches being a six
nucleotide seed match
a seven nucleotide seed match there are
two different types of second nucleotide
seed matches that they're called a seven
mirror m8
or a seven or a1 i won't go into too
much detail we don't have time for that
uh or the eight mirror uh seed match so
an eight likely tight seed match
and basically these go in these are are
ordered here with the increasing
efficiency so the six
nucleotide seed matches are typically
less efficient than the seven nucleotide
seed matches
which are less efficient than the eight
nucleotide seed matches in
repressing target expression so what we
expect to see if this is
this phenomenon is indeed playing a a
role here in in the data and that's what
of course you hope to see because that's
the entire hypothesis
is that if you look at genes that have a
six mer
a seven or a one a seven m a through an
eight merc site
that you would see a proportional
increase in the fold down regulation
of these genes compared to genes that
don't have
any match any seed match with tsi rna
and that's exactly what we see so in the
middle plot you can see the cumulative
distribution
of the fault changes for genes that
don't have a seed match
in black compared to genes that have a
six mirror a seven
or an eight mer seed match and on the
right hand side you can basically see
the median lock to fall changes where
indeed you see a proportional
increase in the lock to fall change down
regulation
when going from no to six mer to seven
mirror
a1 seven or m8 and eight so really
proving and validating
that this technology can reveal its ira
of target effects
when applied in such a setting on cell
lysates
so in order to prioritize the most
important of target genes
in this um in this setting we
looked for of target genes that were
actually recurrent
among multiple of these irnas that were
included in the screen
so we decided to focus on off-target
genes that had at least one eight
mercedes
and of target genes that were at least
down-regulated two-fold
and so when counting for every of those
genes how many times we observed such
enough target gene
across the 86 different sirnas we get
the frequency table that is shown
on the um on the plots on the slide here
on the right
and what was very revealing is that the
second
most frequent of target gene that was
identified was actually tjs beta
receptor one itself
which of course made total sense as this
is one of the major drivers of tgf beta
receptor signaling
so this is really proving that we can
use that technology
to identify relevant of target genes
from such in this irony repurposing
screen
and also interesting to see was that
several other
of these top-ranked genes were also
known components of the teacher's vita
pathway
and interestingly of course for the
customer in this case is that there were
several genes in there that had not been
associated to teach you've made a
pathway activity before
so i want to conclude by by reiterating
that the technologies i presented here
today
being hd pathway seeking hd target seek
are high throughput rna sequencing
technologies that are performed directly
on cell lysates there's no need for rna
extraction so they have the capability
to be performed in high throughput in a
really cost effective
manner so basically all you need to do
is to do is treat your cells with your
compounds or antisense or this iron a
nucleotides
of uh uh is irons of interest
um lice your cells ship the lysates
and that's basically it uh we run hd
pathway seek hd target seek
together with all the proper data
analysis directly on
the shift lysates and provide you back
of course with
the results so with that i want to
end also thank a few people that have
been involved in the development
of these technologies at biogazelle and
also
especially thank galapagos
so for allowing us to share the results
from the fibrosis as irony screen
and i'll leave it here
and thank you for listening thank you
for attending and i'm happy to take
any of your questions thanks
thank you peter for that outstanding
presentation and we will now
move into the live q a portion of the
presentation
and as a reminder to our audience
members please submit your questions
via the q a box so peter let's take a
look we already have some great
questions
coming in from our audience members
and it looks like that we are not seeing
you on
your camera can you hear me peter
now i just thank our audience for their
patience
that does happen on occasion and
it looks like he is trying to get back
on
camera
so peter if you could just go ahead and
turn your camera back on
we will begin the live q a portion
with our audience
and again thank you for these technical
difficulties
they do happen on occasion
and i see that there are already some
great questions so if you haven't asked
a question
go ahead and use that q a box
and um we will begin
all right it looks like he is about to
hop
on
um peter if you can hear me
please turn on your camera
and the right
i'm just going ahead and texting him and
letting him make sure we get him back in
here
every once in a while this happens and i
hope that all of you are enjoying
this conference so far it has been
fabulous
i know i've seen a few of you from room
to room
um in our studios today but if you
haven't had a chance to check out the
agenda
there are quite a few more workshops and
uh seminars
throughout the day um following this one
so we hope that you will join us for
other webinars
as well and um
it looks like he is still trying to
figure it out
this is where i think audience members
begin
to see how long i can possibly stall
and i appreciate all of your patience um
it looks like he is almost
in here
let me go ahead and respond please
go to the bottom
okay i've gone ahead and asked him to
exit the studio
and then come back in and i hope that
the
people that are attending will stick
around
because i think he we are i
already see the questions that have come
in and i think it is going to
be a great live q a so again bear with
me
as we wait for him to log out so he just
logged out
and now he's logging back in
and we should see him
pop up i also want to encourage you to
work on that survey so i know we've
asked you a few questions um
and we appreciate your feedback on that
as you proceed through the different
various webinars um
peter can you hear me i can hear you hi
can you hear me
yay there he is finally and i will tell
you what i
read i will tell you what a great
audience we have
every single one of them are still in
the studio
so thank you to our live audience we
appreciate that
um welcome back peter and we will go
ahead and begin
our q a and it looks like our audience
members have already
provided some great questions so thank
you all for your patience
our first question peter is can this
method
also be used with tissues or biofluids
yeah so um thanks for that question um
so basically uh what i showed in the
presentation is that
we typically work on cell lysates this
works this approach
works well with cultured cells and these
are easy to learn
if you work with tissues or biofluids we
would need to introduce an intermediate
step
before applying the technology and that
stuff would entail an rna extraction
um performed on the fluid or or on the
tissue
before able to do the library
preparation so the method is compatible
the library preparation method
and everything downstream of it is
compatible with tissues
for an extraction on those tissues or
biofluids
and deliver the rna and 9612 plates for
instance
so it can work given that you
and peter thank you so much um
our next question is are there any
scenarios
where you'd recommend using more than
four replicates per condition
um so the muppets
that we suggest to use here is really a
trade-off between
let's say insensitive enough and having
sufficient replicated sufficient power
to detect differential genes
on one hand and on the other hand
stay cost-effective and this is always a
trade-off the more replicates you would
include
the less cost-effective the method would
become of course your cost per condition
would increase
uh but you would gain power and would be
able to identify
let's say uh differential genes uh that
have potentially lower fall changes
a bit more warm or that are lower
abundance
i think four is a is a good
a good trade-off especially if you're
focusing on
differential pathway expression analysis
so the hd pathway ac procedure
for that four is is optimal going lower
would reduce the sensitivity
dramatically this is something we
simulate
going higher may have a small
gain in in outputs but potentially
non-dramatic especially on that
pathway at the g level that's a
different story
thank you so much peter our next
question from our audience member
how about cells cultured in 3d such
as spheroids
well in principle if you can lyse the
cells
then the method can work
perfectly on those lysates so if your
spheroid cultures can be lysed using uh
the lysis protocol that we've helped
this should work perfectly fine what we
always do is
if we would deviate from what we
standardly do which is 2d cell cultures
we always do a very small pilot
where we ask the customer to
grow a few cells at the license buffer
ship as the lysades and then we do a qc
to evaluate whether we can indeed
generate libraries from that type of
material
so this is something we would evaluate
on a case-by-case basis but i definitely
do not we have not done it before
for cultures to be clear but i
definitely don't exclude
the possibility that this could work and
it's very easy to test if it would work
thank you so much peter now what are the
sensitivity limits of the technique in
terms of
number of cells per sample
um so this depends uh
in parts on the cell type some cells are
more transcriptionally active than
others
so depending on the cell type you can
get more rna
per cell what we typically typically in
in 96 well plates work with cell numbers
five thousand ten thousand fifteen
thousand percent it also really depends
on the cell culture conditions and the
optimal conditions for the readout and
the experiment itself and the treatment
and so on so all of these things need to
be taken into account
um the lower the cell number um
or let's say the lower the rna content
of the lysates the few
genes that the methods will detect for
pathway analysis uh this is quite robust
so even
when when decreasing the number of genes
from seven thousand to six thousand to
five thousand
you would still be able to detect a
majority of differential pathways
for differential gene expression
analysis of course this would uh
have an impact thank you so much and we
have time for a couple of more questions
peter how long would it take to see
these newly identified
as that are rnas applied to
fibrosis patients
so i guess this is related to the the
the case uh
i presented uh in the context of
fibrosis where we looked at this irony
of
targets i don't know if the question is
related to how long it would take to see
the off-target effects
of those iron ac patients
that's not something we have
investigated so what we have done is
really the in vitro work the
upfront work where uh we looked at uh
off-target genes for sirnas in
uh that were identified
from the screen how long
these if it would take for these effects
to manifest themselves in patient
samples it's
not something like that let's get it so
thank you so much um we have one more
final question
how do you deal with variation and
sample concentrations
across different wells
um because i see that the connection is
a bit
um before we
actually start seek
384 live experiments already quantified
and boots
uh to based on the library concentration
in order to obtain an ak motor pool and
to get an even
redistribution across samples so there's
an
a step involved that takes care of this
peter i want to thank you again for
presentation today
and for your important research and i
also
i want to take the moment and thank our
audience members for their patience
and their questions any questions
submitted
but not presented at the end of the q a
today will be answered
via email by the address that you
provided
in your contact information thank you
again peter and thank you
to the audience this presentation will
be available for on-demand
viewing for 12 months and please
remember to share it
with your colleagues who may be
interested in the topic today
and don't miss out on the other
presentations in our agenda
visit the agenda tab in the auditorium
for a full
listing thank you again peter and thank
you all
until next time take care stay safe stay
healthy
bye-bye okay thank you so much thanks
for uh for listening thanks for
attending bye